Did you spot all of these moments in the new
trailer for "Across the Spider-Verse?"
We're not horsing around here.
Let us point to some of the small details
you might have missed.
He might be on the road to a trip across dimensions,
but before he can start on that journey, Miles
still has some local small-time crooks to
deal with.
But in classic Spider-Man fashion, these happen
to be villains with exceptionally wild powers.
The walking, talking bread dispenser found
stealing from a convenience store is Johnathon
Ohnn, also known as the Spot.
This is a bad guy covered in inter-dimensional
portals that make him a nightmare for any hero.
In "Peter Parker, the Spectacular Spider-Man"
#98, Dr. Jonathon Ohnn is sucked into a strange
black portal and becomes a super-powered being
called The Spot.
That comic marked the beginning of his career
as part of Peter Parker's rogues' gallery.
He wasn't originally an enemy of Miles Morales,
but it's nothing new for the "Spider-Verse"
series to play fast and loose with its heroes
and villains.
In a sequel that's already going to send Miles
slipping in and out of portals, seeing him
tackle someone who can create them at will
is guaranteed to spark some fantastic sequences.
We can't wait to see them.
In the first movie in the "Spider-Verse" series,
one thing was made abundantly clear:
"Anyone can wear the mask.
You could wear the mask!"
Well, there's a whole bunch of new masks to
spot in the sequel's second trailer.
While there are plenty of returning favorites
here to catch your eye, as well as some oddballs
like Spider-Horse, the trailer also gives
us our first good look at some of Miles' new allies.
There's Jessica Drew, also known as Spider-Woman,
riding in on her bike while bearing a baby bump.
There's also Hobart "Hobie" Brown, the Spider-Punk,
along with Pravitr Prabhakar, otherwise known
as Spider-Man India.
Jessica Drew is a storied character from Marvel
Comics, but Spider-Punk and Spider-Man India
might be a little more obscure.
The guitar-rocking hero Spider-Punk debuted
in 2014, and this version sounds like a Londoner,
unlike the New York-based rebel from the comics.
Spider-Man India is based on a four-issue
run of comics that retells Spidey's story
in an Indian setting.
Beyond them, one of the real winning shots
of the trailer involves the appearance of
Ben Reilly, the infamous Scarlet Spider.
Two things set Ben apart from his contemporaries.
First, he looks cool, sporting a stylish blue
hooded vest.
Second, in the comics, he is actually a clone
of Peter Parker created by villain Miles Warren,
the Jackal.
This means that there is a chance that this
Scarlet Spider is actually one of two Spider-Men
from the same dimension.
Although Ben was created to be a villain and
replace Peter Parker, in the comics, he finds
himself compelled to fight for the forces
of good.
Before long he becomes one of Peter's allies.
Popping up in his first comic in 1975, the
Scarlet Spider became a huge part of Spider-Man lore.
For a time, he was even considered the main
comic Spider-Man.
This occurred when Norman Osborn convinced
the two web crawlers that Peter Parker was
in fact the actual clone.
The two then switched places, and Ben took
over the mantle thinking he was the original superhero.
It will be interesting to see how the filmmakers
adapt such a complicated and major part of
Spider-Man continuity for the world of "Spider-Verse"
– or if they go there at all.
Facing issues like bad guys and bad grades,
it's understandable why Miles would take the
first chance he gets to get away from his
world and into another ... or ten.
As revealed by Gwen, the Lobby is a creation
of Miguel O'Hara, a hero from a futuristic
world who has teamed up with the best bunch
of web-slingers he can find.
Unfortunately, it seems that Miles hasn't
made the list, for some reason or another.
"You can never be part of this.
And don't even get me started on Doctor Strange
and the little nerd back on Earth-199999."
Now, while this will no doubt get lovers of
the live-action MCU excited about the streams
crossing, it's worth noting that the numbers
don't quite add up in regard to the Earth
mentioned here.
"Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness"
pegs the MCU we know as Earth-616.
However, many more comics-focused fans see
the MCU as being set more accurately in Earth-199999.
Could this be the first step in getting an
animated Tom Holland swinging alongside Miles Morales?
In the spider-verse, anything is possible.
"Peter!"
"Yeah?
Oh, sorry, did you mean me?"
Speaking of Peter, the trailer sees Peter
B. Parker from the first movie making a welcome re-appearance.
As expected, he is now a proud father to a
baby girl named May.
Swinging through the air without a care in
the world, May "Mayday" Parker is based on
Spider-Girl, who debuted in 1997 as part of
a "What If?" story.
A member of the MC2 universe, an alternative
future timeline, she is the super-powered
daughter of Peter Parker.
Given her age and Peter's brief appearance
in the trailer, we wonder if Peter will be
taking a back seat this time around, with
an even greater focus on Miles.
Even though Peter has seemingly been accepted
into O'Hara's team of web slingers, it doesn't
mean he'll be the most active member of the
team.
He is a father now, after all, and there's
a high chance that he'll only appear alongside
his former protégé in a mentor capacity.
As much as Miles appears to want to join the
new Spider-Club, it seems that there's a toll
for entry that he might not be willing to
pay.
As explained by Miguel O'Hara, also known
as Spider-Man 2099, being Spider-Man is a sacrifice.
"You have a choice between saving one person
and saving every world."
Is the seeming threat to Miles' dad a double
bluff?
It could be - but as any fan of Spider-Man
knows, losing a family member is inevitable
with this job.
Closing off this eye-watering preview, there's
a chunkier dose of spider versus spider as
Miles and Miguel battle on what looks like
a futuristic bullet train with other Spider-Folk,
including Peter and Gwen, trailing closely
behind.
Peter tells Miguel that this isn't what the
futuristic crime fighter promised, suggesting
that this fresh dose of power might've gone
to O'Hara's head.
Whatever it is he has planned, though, Miles
isn't signing up for it.
In what feels like a final battle moment that
you'd expect would be tucked away until the
film's release, Miles looks to be charging
up against Miguel and saying he's "going to
do his own thing."
The question is, what kind of ramifications
could that have on all the universes?
If the MCU and "Into the Spider-Verse" have
taught us anything, it's that throwing things
out of interdimensional whack causes serious
problems.
With that in mind, could the film end with
Miles' actions having a negative impact and
Miguel being in the right after all?
Given that this is the second part of a planned
trilogy, who can say?
Either way, our Spidey-Senses are well and
truly tingling.
If we were to go over all the Spider-Man suits
we spotted in this trailer, it would take
all day.
Nonetheless, it's worth mentioning that one
decidedly more equine version of the character
makes a blink-and-you-miss-it appearance just
before the preview ends.
Right as the amusing Spidey-to-Spidey therapy
session gets interrupted by Miles and a giant
mass of Spider-People crashing through the
wall, viewers can see that one of them is
actually a horse wearing a Spider-Man mask.
Because this is a comic book movie we're talking
about, this bizarre Spider-Horse actually
has canonical precedent in the source material.
His name is Widow, and he gains his superpowers
when he is bitten by a radioactive spider
along with the Wild West-inspired Patrick
O'Hara, aka Web-Slinger, Widow's human partner.
Miles also crosses paths with these characters
in the comics, even inducting them into his
Web-Warriors team at one point to fight a
Multiversal threat.
Could a similar partnership form between these
characters in the movie?
Perhaps, but it looks like this majestic beast
of a Spider-Animal might be starting off on
the wrong foot with Miles ... or hoof, that
is.
In any case, it's nice to see that Widow is
carrying on the Spider-Animal legacy for "Across
the Spider-Verse" — it's currently unknown
whether or not John Mulaney's Spider-Ham will
be making a return appearance.
"Into the Spider-Verse" is full of great tunes,
but Blackway and Black Caviar's "What's Up
Danger" is arguably the standout song of the
movie.
The official trailer for "Across the Spider-Verse,"
released in December, also uses the song,
carrying on its legacy.
While two times might be a coincidence — or
in this case, a handy audio callback to the
greatness of the first "Spider-Verse" movie
— this second "Across the Spider-Verse"
trailer also uses "What's Up Danger" so very,
very prominently that the intention is clear.
Every major superhero either has or would
greatly benefit from an instantly recognizable
theme song.
This trailer goes a long way toward establishing
this track as an anthem for Miles.
If you've spent any time on the internet at
all, you've almost certainly bumped into that
meme where two 1960s cartoon Spider-Man characters
are pointing at each other.
The good people at Sony and Marvel are well
aware of the popular image — to the point
that in 2022, the official @SpiderManMovie
Twitter page even recreated it with "Spider-Man:
No Way Home" stars Tobey Maguire, Andrew Garfield,
and Tom Holland.
The "Spider-Verse" people are also very familiar
with the meme.
It popped up in the first film as a post-credits
sequence when we got our first look at Miguel
O'Hara, and the new trailer ramps the meme
up further than you might think was even possible.
The trailer devotes but a few short seconds
to the gradual escalation of the pointing
scenario and the ensuing confusion, but it's
already hilarious enough to make the viewer
not-so-secretly hope that the full movie will
turn it into an extended gag.